please join with me in a pledge to Oh
Glory
I pledge allegiance
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
all right thank you all
right
the whole committee work session on
Senate Bill 11 relative to
African-American
of burial grounds uh
the
we're here to talk about where we are in
this uh this attempt at working a
working the issue to come out with a
a bill
that uh
we can
we can move forward with
uh
we s
but right now uh
we've had some oh
oh okay yeah I know that's better that's
too many too many I'm too laid back a
person but we're any further back I'd be
I'd be uh they'd be throwing Dirt on My
Grave
they say oh he looks he's dead
okay
all right uh
we've
I'm trying well the goal I I think we've
tried with the work with this work
session has been
to try to come to some kind of
agreement
that we could
we could have a
if not a majority
at least excuse me it's not a unanimous
at least a strong majority
on the uh
for a for an amendment to you know and
pass the the bill because they I think
we do see value
at least uh relative to this bill
from last last session when the interim
study that we did
uh
the right now I've haven't
I don't believe we're there
not even close I we haven't had much in
the way of
of this of any
any meeting of the minds
uh
that's why I canceled
the executive session I didn't believe I
uh to go into executive session uh and
it would be unfair
to have a meeting and have people
uh
being assigned to vote
on
on the the executive session
and not have it so that's why I canceled
it uh what I'm going to propose
is
a
subcommittee
of so of
individuals
it'll be an even subcommittee
uh
proposing is this is a gum going to
propose a subcommittee
uh
where we the the subcommittee would be
charged with coming up with a
bipartisan
Amendment
to be able to to be a bipartisan
amendment to be able to uh
get enough on the bill
to make both
and that's I haven't going to propose it
but not yet I want to have here to some
discussion on that
representative wrong
thank you Mr chair
representative Darby has done extensive
research on this bill he's talked to a
lot of stakeholders
um I I actually think the work he's done
would be the same work that a
subcommittee would do so I'd like to
suggest that he give a background a
summary of what he's done and what he's
um you know some of the the learnings
he's had because I think we may have the
information after that to just to be
able to move forward to schedule the
executive session and as far as not
knowing where people stand I it might be
worthwhile also to go around the
committee and ask people where they
stand because I don't even know my ex
outside of our caucus I don't know where
people stand on this bill there may be
people that you know would support an
amendment consistent with the research
we
representative the KIPP thank you Mr
chairman uh yeah I think I appreciate
representative brung's comments and all
the work that representative Darby has
done and I think it's uh equal to the
work that a lot of us have done myself
included I think I'll probably put in
about the same amount of time with
representative Darby has and appreciate
his uh 12 30 in the morning emails
including the last two drafts I actually
haven't seen the official drafts of his
latest two amendments uh from OLS I
suspect he has copies for us now so I'm
looking forward to reviewing those so
we've got three amendments floating
around there now and it's hard to form
an opinion on those until we see those
drafts and I think that's the intent of
of the subcommittee here we have you
know 20 or 18 or so members and three
amendments
so it's a lot of cooks if we have a
small group that can look at those three
amendments and perhaps come up with one
out of those three or combination of
wording out of those three amendments
and then present it to the larger group
a single bipartisan Amendment
I mean I think it we want to it sounds
like we want to pass something
that satisfies the bipartisan group of
sponsors of Senator Waters Senator
Carson Senator avard and others
um
I I spoke just last night with the uh
you know I got a call from Jennifer at
the New Hampshire preservation society
and who was quite pleased with the
amendment that I last presented I spoke
last night at an event with Senator
Carson uh and she had some
you know some input so there's a lot of
information floating around there that I
think that would be useful in the
subcommittee so rather than pulling the
committee now in advance
before they have all the information I
think we ought to go
to a subcommittee
that's the purpose of a subcommittee is
to to let them
chew on all the data and then report
back to the larger committee and I don't
even really care to be on the
subcommittee to be honest with that I
will I'll happily serve if the chair
wants me to
um but other other folks can can serve
representative La Montagne
thank you Mr chair I
I think we're all here now we've all
here we've come here to do the work of
studying the bill together
and I don't see
why we can't
um spend the time now
to see if we can't come up with a bill
that we can exec on in the future even
if it is a subcommittee within this
group here that does most of the talking
about it I think we can get there
representative Darby oh by the way I did
get uh your uh uh the emails that you
sent me and I am impressed what you've
done so uh
thank you and thank you for uh
um so I I am with uh representative
LaMontagne I'm I'm not making a taking a
statement on making a position on
whether or not we should have a
subcommittee but I do think that there's
some value in getting out the discussing
the positions and what the approaches
are to
um various amendments and so that we can
hear from the members of the committee
about where their concerns might be in
together rather than in a smaller form
um and I think you know I I've
um I spent a few minutes
um you know with representative Donnelly
represent representative McHugh last
last week and um and I think that it'd
be better to rather than having sort of
these one and two one and two Z
discussions like you mentioned I I'd
sent you some some inputs
um
just to just to lay out if they're just
to hear where the concerns are and where
the
um
the where the areas of compromise need
to be
any other uh
um
I I guess I'm I'm I feel like we haven't
really worked we had work sessions where
we heard other people speak to us but
personally I don't feel like we've had a
chance to talk to each other about where
the issue is and I'm really confused
about where the sticking point is
because originally when this bill came
to us I was like why do we need this we
treat I I don't understand why are we
making this specific and special to
African-Americans so I went and did some
homework on my own and realized that
they were slaves they didn't have last
names they couldn't be traced I went to
the Portsmouth the new Memorial I read a
lot about how these human beings were
treated as property and not any better
than a tractor or a cow you know they
when they were done with them they were
just discarded and now in my heart I
truly believe that we need to do what is
right and just and respectful and
graceful with those human bones and and
I'm I'm unsure where we're sticking in
in these amendments and this issue and
and I really need some help getting
getting understanding that thank you
representative of the Q
would the would the member
would would you believe that the state
archaeologist testified that they in
fact do that now and would you believe
would you further believe that I agree
with you that it wouldn't hurt at all
for us to codify
what what you said
he did say that you go through that but
he also but he said their track through
last names
you know and so then indentured
Serpentine they attract these these
beings are tracked through last names
slaves didn't have last names
so I guess what I'm saying is I agree
with you and
and this bill
I like you thought initially
we may not we may not need this because
from my research in current law and
sitting with OLS
asking them to help me fix this bill
they informed me
and in reviewing the testimony I thought
why do we need this bill because it
appears that current statute
calls for the treatment of remains
respectfully of all Origins regardless
of origins or circumstances of
discovering it
or what have you but because I had
similar feelings that the you just
expressed
all the the same feelings that there's
absolutely no harm and certainly some
good done
by codifying and calling out
certain groups as precedent has
already been set
federally and in in New Hampshire
statute for Native Americans
so I essentially agree with you but I
also think that we we agreed in the
beginning that
it it may or may not be necessary but
it's not a bad not a bad idea and
there's some sentiment I think
in parts of the legislature
that
in general
cultural Racial equality is a good thing
isn't always a good thing unless there's
some justification to do that like there
clearly was for Native Americans and may
clearly be for African Americans in this
during that you know in this case
in this case so I think that's we're
just trying to hammer out how exactly we
do that where to put it in law
and maybe in some people's minds and I'm
not speaking I can't speak for other
people really
if we do that but I I think there's
enough consensus to do something is just
to do exactly how to do it we've seen
well at least one option in my amendment
I haven't seen the official versions
from OLS I did see the Google Doc
version from representative Darby
um
but I'm representative do you have the
OLS versions that you can circulate
around they I have one they were only
they were only produced today at I'm
they were only delivered today at 8 52
and then there was a printer malfunction
so okay here's here's one well we will
we'll still be here for another three or
representative wolf before we start
passing out duck oh too late well
I'd like to just resolve what you just
said Mr McHugh representative McHugh if
we're on an agreement that it should be
pardon
I'd like to resolve what you have just
goodness in in the last Representatives
comments can we work on those before we
start going through these three
amendments I didn't get them last night
I haven't seen any of these amendments I
got a notice at three o'clock that the
executive session was canceled and I was
not real happy with that so I think we
ought to start to proceed and see
whether there's a general agreement that
we are going to proceed
and then we'll take
representative Darby so we can take
yours I I don't know what they all are
you want to say something yeah look
yeah go ahead yeah I didn't I didn't
know you later on to say so
thank you Mr chair
um even without looking at
representative Darby's Amendment
if we're having a general discussion
about as Mr Wolf says where are we going
perhaps I'd if if he'll entertain a
question
what is wrong with Mr McHugh's amendment
that takes it and puts it in with the
Native Americans but puts it in my
memory is last time Mr Dobby was not
happy with that Amendment but if if he's
able to accept that Amendment without 10
other amendments or tell us why you
don't like it then maybe as Mr Wolf
asked representative wolf asks maybe we
could figure out is there any option to
make an agreement yeah sure it's it's
pretty straightforward
um
there's two there's two pretty
significant issues with that Amendment
the first is that it um really
co-mingles this language with the nagra
apparently I I can't speak loud sorry
um there's really two significant uh
errors one is that really co-mingles the
language about Native Americans with
that modeled after the nagpra law which
is based on federal statute
um in particular the first section of
his Amendment
um
is is really just it doesn't fit into
the intent of the bill and it doesn't
fit in with the
um uh with the the process that's why
when the state archaeologist
um testified he was very confused
because it just the location of that
text does not make sense and when I went
and talked to OLS because of course I
did that and I did not say when I talked
to OLS I didn't say please draft this
for me what I said is here's the
sections that
um that
I see this is how I I don't want to
I don't believe
um that the nagpra related statute
should be modified
um because there's traceability so
there's that one section
but the other section and the much much
more important section
is the original Bill had a new
um chapter called number 289 24. in that
in that bill and which is pretty similar
to this amendment the um the last
paragraph of 289-24
talked about returning remains and
gravesite artifacts that are held in
collections that was stripped out of the
um of uh representative mchughes excuse
me
I just could I interrupt for a minute
I'm really distracted
by this other conversation going on
while we're
trying to have a hearing together and I
find it really discourteous to will that
so so those are the two main problems
with uh representative McHugh's
Amendment
um I I agree honestly and the and the
amendment that I have here tries to do
exactly what representative Amendment
tries to do which is
um which is more appropriately aligned
um the the changes intended by the bill
with existing statute but note
um there are there are multiple um there
are multiple cases of you know
African-American remains there's
African-American remains when you just
just discover bones that's the cut
that's what
um
227 a c uh covers there's
um African-American remains where
um as Senator Waters has informed us in
the past are just outside of the
cemetery boundaries it's pretty easy to
find just with simple Google searches
and I'm happy to share this research
where these cases exist today in
um in Southern New Hampshire it's easy
to find cases where there are believed
to be African-American remains that have
not been reinterred that are not that
are not marked on the edges of
graveyards or on private property it is
easy to find this just with casual
research
um
so uh so that's the other side of these
other sections the other sections are
where we have a
um an abandoned graveyard
um that's uh and then there's the
sections on returning
um you know returning artifacts and in
particular remains so they can be
reinterred and that has to be and that
absolutely has to be accounted for in
this
in the bill in the um in an amendment if
all right
we're doing exactly now
what I've been trying to get rid of and
that is here's mine there it is and okay
here's mine there it is and
I'm not going to move from that
what I'm proposing with a subcommittee
is you get yours you get yours
let's see if we can now come into the
into the middle or and get something
that everybody can agree on do it like
they do in Congress you want something
you want something okay let's now put it
together and see if we get something
not like Congress they do a lot of money
but that's what that's what I'm trying
to propose with a subcommittee is to be
able to make a compromise bill
away and put I want to get a win-win
situation
that's what I'm proposing I know that's
asking a lot in the political
environment
and the only way I've ever seen it done
is when people will you know be willing
to compromise
uh
if we can't do it then let me know and
then we'll just stay here and fight for
laughs
thank you Mr chair
um I don't know that I have a position
on whether there should be a
subcommittee or not um but I do just
we're talking about something that's
really sensitive and we're trying to
focus on the importance of in part of
having
um consultation and conversation with
descendant communities of
African-American people who have passed
and been buried
and I just want to recognize that
um
we unfortunately don't have any of those
Folks at the table right now and so I
think I just want to be really sensitive
that
um
this is a little bit different than
um the average conversation that we're
going to have in the house and that I'm
not sure
um I'm not sure what winning looks like
so I'm just really sensitive that uh
however we move forward
um that we can Center the people and the
souls and their descendants of the folks
who that were who were talking about
thing
you asked for both
who has not no no she has spoke spoken I
just want to make certain I get the rest
of the
it was just brought up there are no
African African Americans in this
committee
I think that is one of the issues we're
dealing with
I think that the afro-americ
African-American Community back and I'm
not saying now I'm saying back then were
afforded no dignity and I think that the
fact that we're diddling around with
this rather than getting something
passed means they've already waited
hundreds of years
for that dignity and we should provide
it for them that's what I think
so you're not you're not into giving oh
oh forget it there isn't if I'm not
mistaken
uh
senator
uh you have uh mentioned that you have a
some background and uh
some of your heritage is uh
African-American
okay if you've I think you've said that
your testimony thank you Mr chairman um
and I know and I know your District Four
so I wasn't quite here I I remember the
black Heritage Trail of New Hampshire on
board of directors and uh have worked
extensively
um with the black Heritage Trail of I
mean New Hampshire on on you know and
and uh and descending community on these
projects for decades no but I mean I
think the
the representative is concerned that
there's no one in this uh uh in the on
in this committee who has any uh
African-American uh uh background you
know uh you know there were no
bloodlines
uh and uh I think you have
post-testified that you have
um thanks for your question I have an
interracial family
um myself I I do not to my knowledge
have African-American descent but I have
uh my family is um I know Jesse Waters
says he does
on television
but but no let me just say that I I
think that the wisdom of this committee
to sensitively
um understand and learn about
um concerns the African American
Community
um is what we do as legislators so I
think that
um you know the sensitivity here is is
what we're all about and I think we all
share in that so I I appreciate the
committee's interest thank you and thank
you all right I think uh do you haven't
yeah you haven't you haven't spoken
thank you Mr chair
um I just wanted to say I think we're
all very sensitive to what's going on
and that's why it's there's so much
deliberation but I I was just hoping we
could get back to the point of it seems
like we need to decide if we want to the
subcommittee or not well uh isn't that
the question if we could get back to
that well let me let me tell you this
uh
I can
as chair
I can just
call ASAP for a subcommittee
and
you don't have to participate people
don't have to participate but I would
hope they would because it would make no
no value so that's why I'm putting it to
the
to the uh to to the committee
so sorry sorry uh follow up um so so do
we at this point go around are you
asking for a consensus or no what
is the next step to to decide making the
decision eventually I will probably ask
for consensus so I can find at least
six to eight people who are willing to
put their uh sides
there
their positions aside and accept yes for
an answer
and then make work a
work out a bill that could be acceptable
to everyone if it's not possible then
okay
and we'll let the we'll let it we'll let
representative wolf and then
representative rock it seems to me
from listening to the discussions that
there's a disagreement between
representative McHugh and representative
Darby on what would be the best
Amendment no I don't see well okay
that's not what I'm asking for that's
what I'm hearing on this discussion
representative McHugh said he didn't
care to be on the committee the
subcommittee Etc
I'm suggesting that representative
McHugh representative Darby and two
others come together make this committee
but they have to be on it they're the
ones that are
have the sticking points at least in my
opinion
representative rock thank you Mr chair
this is a work session and I guess I'm
really frustrated because we're going
around and around talking we have three
amendments we have a lot of work that
everyone's done I just don't think it's
worthwhile to prolong this and kick the
can down the road with having a
subcommittee I think we've all come from
all corners of New Hampshire today on
the taxpayers dime to to work on this
bill let's use now to review the
Amendments this isn't about winning this
is about finding a bill that can capture
and apply dignity to the remains of
African Americans who are likely
enslaved we have three amendments I know
that with the testimony we had at the
last work session there were flaws in
representative Magoo's
Amendment which were discussed I mean if
representative Darby brought those up
um let's start from there let's start
from the other amendments and just get
this thing going I I can't see where a
subcommittee can do anything that we
[Music]
thank you Mr chairman
so I I don't I don't see the flaws
um in in discussing it with the drafting
attorneys
they took the
they made the recommendations
on how to draft
the prime sponsors bill
um
and uh you know I've discussed with the
prime sponsors and repeatedly with OLS
the right way to draft
this language to accomplish what the
prime sponsors want
including Senator Carson and Senator
Waters
who's the Prime uh and Senator avard and
some of the other folks and most
importantly this bill will get amended
so we'll need concurrence last night
speaking with um
representative Wilhelm who mentioned he
might might speak with the
representative Simpson on our committee
here
and Senator Carson who will speak with
Senator Pearl who chairs Edna who will
have to concur with this
so nothing gets done without concurrence
let's let's be mindful of that that's
the process
right so if we want to get this bill
done like fully done into law
we'll need that concurrence
right that's what happens after the
house passes it assuming the house
passes it if we get this bill out of
here with a good recommendation
hopefully on consent
with a strong house position
that's our best chance to get
concurrence
out of Senator Pearl
right and I had that discussion last
night
with with them uh in person
so my recommendation to this committee
is to take the closest position to the
prime sponsors in a a very long list of
bipartisan Senate sponsors who have a
strong position on this bill and the in
our closest position is that first
amendment that was drafted not by
representative McHugh but by a team of
OLS attorneys they review it amongst
themselves to make sure it's technically
accurate
right now we've taken the thoughtful
language of Senator Waters
and put it in the right places
and the reason that 2028 date was taken
out was to make the return of those
remains fourth width we all know what
fourth width means we also want to make
this law endure past 2028.
right so I don't see other flaws in this
and that's not my opinion that's the
opinion of a bunch of good legal Minds
so that's my opinion if you want to get
it done that's how we get it done I mean
and I mean fully across the Finish Line
in the statute
because there'll be all those other
steps that's that's my current opinion
representative Ryan and represent
representative
I I'm new at this I'm confused
I've been an educator for a very long
time
and a social worker we have a problem
right I personally feel like we are
bringing all these other invisible
people into this problem that are um
hearsay or secondhand information and
we're not addressing the problem the
problem is
we have a bill
do we agree on this bill or not we're
here to work today I feel like those
hard conversations need to happen here
um and we need to figure out before we
get into the weeds of the amendments
what exactly is the problem that we're
facing right now
deal with that problem and then move
forward and decide if we need a
committee to resolve it I don't know if
we're going to make consensus
I don't feel like we need the you win I
win I I feel like we we haven't gotten
to the core and the root of our work and
I don't feel like we've done work on
this committee on this bill and today
I'm prepared to stay to have those hard
conversations to work this bill until
it's something that we can agree on or
agree to disagree on thank you
representative Darby and
who else had their hand up on this site
well I know I I have I know you're
you're definitely did you have uh I do
yeah I want him first yeah okay then
then yeah
you're right um
you know with respect to what uh
representative McHugh just said maybe we
can hear from
um the prime sponsor Senator Waters
um about his position on
um uh representative accusement
Amendment
well definitely Senator you uh this is a
work session so uh just you want to say
something this is uh
I'm pretty I'm
a lot less formal in a work section well
thank you Mr chairman and you could stay
there what yes and don't participate I I
appreciate that um I really respect the
process in this committee and um and I I
as a senator don't want to feel that in
any ways that I'm kind of casting
opinions on the process that you have
because this is a great committee and I
really appreciate the Amendments and the
work that's been done this and I'm
grateful for that
um when I look at what representative
McGuffin done I think he has found a way
to get to the heart of this bill which
is just a consultation with the Senate
Community to make sure that's happening
and then also to make sure that we get
materials out of collections that have
been there for far too long and to make
sure we have a process for that and I
think that his version accomplishes that
I know there's um kind of one piece that
is left out of there that is included in
representative Darby's that people have
some care for and I think
philosophically I have care for that as
well but I think the functionality of
the bill is achieved successfully in the
version that the representative has
brought forward
um I just wanted to make a clarification
which is if we do if we were to end up
with any sticking points with the Senate
we would also have the opportunity of a
committee of conference if they were
small different disagreements so I just
wanted to add that to the process
conversation
okay
Mr chair may I ask a question of Senator
Waters
um Senator Waters you mentioned there
was something a sticking point in uh
representative Magoo's amendment that
was included in representative Darby's
um could you specify what that is
I don't mean to say it's a sticking
point but I know that there's
um and I had in my original bill that uh
which is in the very end of
Representative Darby's Amendment
um
it's the policy statement basically
that I mean I that's that's the impetus
for me but on the other hand it's the
effect that counts is The Descendant
Community going to be respected and and
brought in and news remains can be
treated respectfully in the version by
representative yes they are
um our our archaeological
and remains and other other items that
are in collection is going to be found
and respectfully dealt with
they are
um so I I think that's that's that's the
that's the heart of the bill and I would
add this came out of Senate DNR so it's
going to come back to enr and I I have a
feeling that the Senate will be pleased
to see a successful resolution to this
uh well follow-up um so Senator Waters
if that policy statement was added to Mr
representative mague's Amendment would
um you have my original bill but as I
said I I respect the process here I I
see a consensus here in trying to do
something that addresses the two key
issues so um in some ways the policy
statement
is a is a valuable is valuable as a
commitment of policy on the back of the
State of New Hampshire but on the other
hand the policy if it's enacted also
represents that value so I'm not just
playing with words I I appreciate the
spirit of this committee and the
conversation and I respect the way that
you feel you can best move forward so I
I'm not trying to you know kind of pivot
and wiggle away but I I hope you hear me
say that I you know I value the result
okay one last question Mr chair
um and I want to direct this to
representative Darby so
we have we have representative miku's
Amendment the policy statement
it it it establishes policy it
establishes the position of the state
and as it's implemented further down in
the bill
um
I forget Mr representative Darby there
was another issue with
um
uh representative McHugh's amendment
that that may be able to be improved
upon can you I know you were you were
discussing it when he was having a
private conversation with Senator Waters
and it was distracting so could you just
um just trying to collect my
I want to phrase this
um the the two things that I brought up
um was the
um co-mingling of the um the uh the
statutes based on nagpro with um uh
African-American um remains and the
um
the this position of remains and
um gravesite artifacts from private
collections those are the two
um
I
understand that
um representative McHugh's Amendment
attempts to address the latter of those
two in
I don't have the amendment in front of
me but it's in the first section it's at
the bottom of the first section
um
the
that when when I spoke to
um when I spoke to OLS and I spoke to
the same lawyer
um that did not come across and this is
this is really I think an inappropriate
place for this statement but
um honestly I think that Senator Waters
is much closer to the African-American
Community than I am
um and I think that if he thinks that
this meets the intent of his original or
it makes good strides towards the intent
of his original bill then I would be
all right
you have a question all right love home
love you okay please
um thank you for accepting my question
I feel like to do this work
um
we just received some of this
information in front of us is it
possible to take both of the documents
Side by each and give us three minutes
to just read them without interruption
uh yeah a lot of when we go for
you have a piece
yeah it is and I'll make a choice a
decision on that in a second let's I
want to go over people who have hands up
uh representative McHugh thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative brung
for bringing up that policy statement
issue uh representative Darby brought it
up when he first noticed that it was
missing
um I actually hadn't noticed that it was
missing because I didn't request that it
be removed so I inquired why that was
taken out uh to OLS because like I think
like I've mentioned a couple of times
um it wasn't my intent to alter
the language per se and certainly not
the intent of the bill
um it was just to get it in the right
spots in the proper form when I went to
OLS the drafting attorney
so I went circled back and said where'd
that go and the answer was it's removed
during chaptering number one
number two we don't typically so the the
law is the policy statement passing the
law is the policy statement the policy
statement is essentially Superfluous
right it is
you can put it there we don't typically
do that anymore we have done it in the
past there are you can find policy
statements in other places in in RSA
um it it's unnecessary it does
communicate legislative intent
um
but the potential problem with doing it
here I'm sure you can
figure out
how it might cause somebody to pull it
off consent or make an issue of it down
the road somewhere so if we want to get
it done
it could be
and I'm I'm theorizing
it might make it a better bill
to keep it out
I'm not necessarily opposed to it either
way
but my objective is to get it done
and
so I circled back again I didn't
expressly ask that they delete it I did
go back and ask why
and the reason wasn't take it out to
help you get it passed but when I
thought about it
and thought about somebody out of the
400 or 424 who might read it
specifically and think anyways I'm sure
you can make the jump
how how it might how it could how it
could go
especially where often that language
gets removed in chaptering anyways
because it's not the RSA
so that's the that's the language and
thank you Senator waters for supporting
my draft of your bill and thanks for
helping us got to get done
representative wolf thank you Mr
chairman
I think we've heard from the prime
sponsor
I said
on this
that basically
they're accepting of the amendment
that you've introduced
representative McHugh I think
representative Ryan's suggestion for a
three to five minute
review of the documents makes sense
we've gotten it five minutes ago huh I
know I know I'm just trying to move it
forward that's right it makes sense and
I suggest we do it and then we come back
with a straw vote on this thing we can't
accept it today because you didn't call
for it but if we have a straw vote and
we've heard everything around here I
haven't heard anything why we don't
accept the amendment we having to finish
the discussion even on well
I agree we should uh take some time to
read what
what the the actual amendments with the
original bill in hand but also uh
I still have
maybe a forlorn hope of being able to
populate a
uh being able to populate a
a subcommittee
because there are other issues I mean I
would like to
you know maybe a very
I would like to see something that
raises all boats that we make the
mention of all
uh all Races colors Creeds
Etc are treated the same
and you could also I I believe that
there is a special issue a special case
concerning African Americans that should
be addressed but also
the habits have a situation have a have
a bill that specifically also says it
recognizes
the uh all all
the the the
sanctity of all Graves
as well
so that take away the
the the issue of the political issues
that seem to be on the uh to happening
in this country right now but at any
rate
uh I'll take say 15 minutes to read the
bill
say
could I ask the Democrats maybe we can
go across the hall bring your papers
which
would you like to caucus
uh for how long would you lick the
caucus whatever you
have yeah make it 15 minutes Republicans
thank you Mr chair
um after the meeting of our caucus we um
we reviewed both amendments and
um the amendment 1597 the First
Amendment brought to us we think that
that fulfills the intent of what we're
trying to do here we've heard from the
prime sponsor that he's satisfied with
it
the one issue that
um the difference between that and the
Second Amendment which we received today
is regarding the acknowledgment and
treatment of unmarked Graves that but
just the outer boundary of existing
cemeteries and we were wondering if
there is an amendment that could
accomplish that onto the First Amendment
thank you Mr chairman I believe that's
our
I believe it's already covered in
current statute though that's already
covered in current statute
um well I I'm not quite sure in the the
correct chapter it's in involved in and
it is and and the distinction of that
section and why we are we would like to
see that incorporated is that that tends
to be more of a common practice where
African Americans that were likely
enslaved or living during times of
enslavement their remains were buried
outside that was kind of customary then
so we want to see that that's
if I may Mr chairman I I noticed that I
think it's a pretty simple fix that you
could say burial ground or burial
so that that way if there's a formal
burial ground with a number of people or
delineated as a burial ground but if
somebody is just buried randomly out in
the field which is what did also happen
that that just that is a burial so I
would think that representative take a
look and see where it says burial site
just say or burial bearing ground or
burial but that's my I think that's what
representative wrong is trying to get at
is is that um just so I'm perfectly
clear is that
yes okay so remains from a suspected
African-American burial ground
comma or burial
correct
and and uh and then on line 19 yes
burial ground comma or
burial
yes
before we get too far with that though
I did look up the definition of burial
ground and it is I think it covers it it
covers it yeah that's what I thought it
was in current statue it's codified it
already it's very uh it doesn't have to
be a formal burial ground but anywhere
that a person is buried is a burial
ground that's a definition already in
statute I can get it to you but I don't
have it it was a discussion that I that
I had we actually talked about that and
access to it and I had a lengthy
discussion I mean
I I think I nearly got it was late on a
Friday so I nearly got kicked out of the
attorney's office because I was laboring
this point
um anyhow
um
so I'm happy to go back and add those
couple of words but I really don't I
think I'm going to be going to get
pushback and be told that it's redundant
and I'm going to get pointed to the
definition so what we could do is
reference the definition
in statute but again I don't if it's not
already referenced but I don't think
it's I know I'm going to be told it's
not necessary
sorry I'm blab
representative rung I appreciate your
suggestion about further amendments but
I don't mind saying that our caucus
would like a bunch of the more
amendments but um we thought that we
could take a straw poll based upon the
testimony of the senator and other
discussion I heard earlier to see would
we support
representative McHugh's Amendment as
99.9 percent of everything we need to do
and it's Ivory Snow and we can move on
so I'm going to propose that we take a
straw vote so we can move forward and a
positive thing that we're all together
and maybe even go to consent I'm going
to move a straw vote that we accept
if we had the vote would we accept
representative McHugh's Amendment as
written can we take a straw on that and
that might get us going with I just want
to quote someone a very wise person told
me don't allow the perfect to be the
enemy of good so I will agree and I will
I agree that this does get it without
that change 99.9 so I know I will
yeah all right
uh we if you will support
the what is the number of that Amendment
well they will we support
is this a straw poll of one uh
you support one five nine seven H the
amendment in its in its entirety as as
is as proposed proposed
we have a you know it's unanimous of
those
those in attendance by the way too bad
we canceled the executive session Mr
chair
yep too bad we didn't agree to this
because exactly is there any way we can
make a call to the clerk I I know no no
no no
never mind no Wishful
I've read I read the uh I already
checked with the clerk if it were
possible
you cannot do it well we'll just have it
next week
can we put it in the calendar can so
it'll be a week from today yeah okay
unless you want to have a sonar
Bill we all want to come on Monday no I
don't think so on Sunday
uh
well it's
uh I like to eat and then well we have a
we have a Hillsborough County Convention
during lunch on session day that's right
so we can't do it
representative Mr chairman if we have a
vote
earlier in the week well I guess it
doesn't matter because it won't go into
that to the next calendar that's that's
right well the calendar
yeah it'll be next week
yeah could you
would you put it
at 45 because if we're all in favor
we're not going to have any discussion
you're going to open the meeting call
the vote and then we leave we could go
to session oh that'll be great but it's
great if we have a caucus yeah they're
representative it won't be on that
calendar
if you do it at 8 45 in the morning the
calendar is already published
no
this is a fair calendar be out tomorrow
you want to do it tomorrow no no no no
that be the be the next uh the next
session next session
the 18th yeah Mr chairman um I would
suggest if we have it before session
begins it conflicts with caucuses I
suggest even though we may be five or
ten minutes late to the Hillsborough
County uh convention we had to take a
quick vote during lunch perhaps we can
meet first for 10 minutes because we're
only Gathering 20 people rather than the
Hillsborough delegation so maybe if we
have the vote you know for like 10
minutes and then those representatives
from Hillsborough County can go on to
why is it that every time I get
talked out of going uh a lot of keeping
to the procedure get screwed up so
I think the sound we should stick to the
17th stick to the um
okay that's fine 17 nine o'clock uh what
nine o'clock or well I usually like
maybe noon time about 10. how about 10
o'clock no nine o'clock nine o'clock on
yeah
yes
um
thank you
I I wanted to say before we check the
straw poll that
um
I felt like we didn't discuss Darby's
Amendment at all and given that we were
all saying we could support
McHugh's Amendment
that was there not some parts of Darby's
Amendment representative Darby I'm sorry
um that we couldn't also include in this
and could we have any more discussion I
feel like we're done we're done we just
made the agreement
well that yeah but we didn't really have
a discussion well technically everything
on the table technically this is that
amendment is not before the committee
this is a work session
so it will have to be brought to the
committee and then there is the you we
have a uh if if someone wishes to there
could be a an additional Amendment that
is not
you know we we're only ho we're only
Bound by our agreement that we made and
that's
uh well
that's uh that's the agreement we made
uh if somebody who's but nothing will
stop it can stop anybody from
making a following another amendment I
would if it got to that I didn't
however you're known by your word in
this business
so I would be I would be careful doing
that yeah I I'm not saying I'm going
back on I I just felt like the work we
were going to do in this session was
incomplete before we took that straw
poll
it uh representative you might feel in
Open Session
representative Darby's bill was not
discussed I can guarantee you we
discussed it in caucus and I heard
representative rang say you discussed it
in caucus so with both of us discussing
it in caucus and then moving on
representative McHugh's bill it really
was not applicable that we needed to go
back to talk about Darby's Amendment
that's why it was not brought up on the
floor or the con the convention here
but it was definitely discussed in both
caucuses so we think it was covered
we weren't trying to
disrepresentative it was there we
discussed it just so you'll know thank
you
I mean having been here close to 20
years
this is how the sausage is made
that's
that yep uh well I'm gonna join the
meeting